you've probably heard about the latest
Disney flop over a Thanksgiving weekend
but um I haven't personally had a chance
to gloat over it so let's talk about
that uh this is the daily wires report
on it Disney's new animated film wish
failed to perform well at the box office
over Thanksgiving holiday weekend this
especially tough for the studio
following the massive flop of the
Marvels earlier this month wish debuted
in third place at the box office
grossing just 19.5 million in its
three-day opening weekend for an
original Disney film on Thanksgiving
weekend $20 million is uh abysmal and it
got 31 million over the 5-day
Thanksgiving weekend which is also
abysmal this was significantly less than
forecasted and doesn't come close to
recouping the $200 million production
budget and I always have to remind
everyone that when you hear about the
production budget that's that's only uh
the tip of the iceberg because that
doesn't count the marketing budget which
could be even more than than the
production budget